today we will be doing a video ASMR of a
Filipino mother thrashing their son for
not finishing their homework
RJ if you don't finish your homework you
are going to die put tongue in a mouth
[Music]
hey what is going on yeah play boys and
play girl shut Playboy look at your
cutie patootie strutting around like
your ballsack got some juice to them
see walking around like your coochie got
some tighten up who the [ __ ] says that
the funny thing is you know when I go
back to my hometown and I start kicking
it with some regular decent human beings
that's when I start to realize I'm just
a trash bag with mouth on some real [ __ ]
true story when I went back home not too
long ago I went to go meet up with my
friend Phoebe and I had seen her ass in
a very long time but when I showed up to
her apartment she had this big ol pimple
on her forehead Lou now see a normal
human being
after having seen your friend a long
time you would probably look past Mount
Vesuvius and just embraced him with a
big ol hug but no I said her before I
look like I got a Google map pin on the
[ __ ] I said I had to look away because
a pimple looked like the high of Sauron
on the [ __ ] I said the pimple was so
big it had a social security number and
our heart beat to it I said her pebble
was so big her forehead charts her face
child support for that big ass
[ __ ] but Pheebs I love you and
congrats on the baby well let's get into
the video of the day and I got to tell
you people this one is a doozy jumpin
[ __ ] day 101
now they say you should never strike a
child that is not yours well none of you
ungodly little [ __ ] are my kids but I
would beat your ass til loose change
came out your [ __ ] pockets like what
in the [ __ ] there are so many funny
things and so many things wrong in this
video I don't even know where to start
well let's start with this number one
boy me don't get that fake ass I learned
thuggery from wildin out reruns video
looking ass first of all let's talk
about this specific part who the hell
jump somebody by tackling them lifting
them up then gently placing them on the
grass what this 13 year old thugs shot
for a double leg lifted this child up
like a Christian spirit how are you
going to tackle somebody but place them
on the floor like a French croissant on
a baking sheet this child says over yeah
oh oh Genco Genco how you gonna be a
thug but place somebody on the grass
like you put him down tissue paper a
shake hey number two well jump somebody
in the middle of a beautiful forest you
have so many questions like who are your
parents and where do you live you can't
be on some thug [ __ ] but live inside a
national park I don't think that works
that way and if your defense is that
it's just a park in a neighborhood well
you still can't be a thug because no
public park in the hood is that clean
and matte green I'll be real man in all
my life I've never seen somebody get
jumped in the same place Yogi Bear lives
like what gang are you jumping him into
the the Park Ranger Crips
like whatnot cut we don't make no forest
fires in here cut because that she's red
homie here's another point man I don't
care how old you are if you are out
there acting like that saying you're a
thug you guys throw hands like a bunch
of prep school [ __ ] I got a niece
that would [ __ ] all of you up in
immediately Oh David they're just a
bunch of kids they don't know how to
throw hands what are you talking about I
don't give up I'm basing these comments
on children that I know in my
neighborhood these [ __ ] still
take my lunch money I'm an adult listen
once they hit puberty in the hood did
you start robbing people for no goddamn
reason I've seen a 12 year old rob a 2
year old just for the Dukey and his
diapers quints [ __ ] give me yo [ __ ] yo
just to keep it culturally real I don't
ever want to hear a white person talk
about how Asian people are weak or some
[ __ ] because this right here cuz is
[ __ ] weak oh you want proof have you
had an Asian massage before dawg Asian
massages are harder than the hands that
they were throwing in that video
somewhere a tiny cute beautiful little
Chinese masseuse is watching your video
upset at your technique oh yeah you've
called that a Big Bounce that's our
Sunday special I love your [ __ ]
elbow eating this Taiwanese lady once
gave me a massage so deep that [ __ ] hit
my spirit that [ __ ] care about
my body and said you ever get whooped by
a belt on your back so hard your back
just arches of [ __ ] children used to get
that beef so hard in my neighborhood
they would just have a yellow stop sign
with a kid arses back like business but
when your version of an ass whoopin is
probably one of the weakest things I've
ever seen in my life get that [ __ ] out
of here
that's a Sunday Taiwanese special [ __ ]
you call that jumping somebody in most
people beat their dig harder than you
smack that kid
listen Davis so does not condone
violence and I don't believe in beat the
kids but people beat your [ __ ] kid I
mean I guess it really depends but if
your kids got white boy amnesia
such as this just dropkick them a couple
of times in the head real quick I
remember I'm high well everybody that's
it for this video you guys know what it
is I'll see y'all next time
boo hey what is going on everybody if
you guys don't already know you already
know I got that patreon if you want to
support this uncensored content because
this video is gonna be be monetized I
already know for a fact I said way too
many [ __ ] if you can check out the
patreon we got a lot of exclusive stuff
and this is where I really get to
connect with you guys and and just as a
patron
said is not really so much about the
extra content that you're getting you're
really supporting me and we are gonna
get to talk and converse and get to know
each other I'll be sharing a lot of
personal stuff that other people will
not see on this channel and it's just
for you guys out there so thank you and
if you can't support the picture are the
best cool to men just come back and
watch every week like comment and share
I love you [ __ ] guys peace